welcome to this video playing wargasm
okay Kings Indian probably what line
that looks a bit like a sideline no he
goes for g3 huh okay may I can transpose
into a Ben Oni yeah let's try to get to
benoni here trying to be quick yeah I
really have no no deep knowledge or any
knowledge hey how is this play can I do
this maybe trying to arrest him with
night h5 hmm ok nite age 5 ok at least I
think yes probably he will go back all
the way out to d2 yeah okay Quincy one
something that you can play it's not a
particularly bad idea you can also just
play for I guess ok ok let's play some
normal be normal looking let's say been
only moves it's not exactly an opening
that I have a huge experience and
yeah I was really wondering about that
maybe yeah he can do that okay so 94 is
losing an exchange takes takes legit
five I would like to play that move but
that seems it's not possible maybe i can
track and you can trade a PA of nights
at least be four before and then if five
might come really quickly maybe but ok
I'm glad that I've gotten rid of one
pair of nights that's normally an
achievement for black because you have
less space you're glad that you get a
little bit get get something traded to
get more maneuvering space ok I can
begin I can go h5 to provoke g5 then
night over to e5 enters h three Pawn
might be a weakness I don't know that so
that's an interesting way to play it
I'm ahead on the clock for once 95f form
and I cannot go to sea for that's a home
so probably I have to have to just cover
the six for the moment I've bishops III
yes yeah yeah I see ya this is it has
some point but he also has weakened his
position a bit with this Jeep on move
and I wonder for children let's say
taking queens III check i can go back
hmm I wonder Knight e5 f4 I wonder if f4
is really helping him this is so not
entirely clear to me hmm
f5 teaks Knight takes Knight g5 check
that that's definitely a problem
Jim I'm not sure about all that i really
don't don't understand this position
wanted to have some some something
against the beep on with the rook night
only form with the tricky piece position
that that is okay I'm trying to provoke
f4 now I mean I'm really not sure if it
is helping him yeah that was Kelly am
but I don't know if it is as mentioned
this is also quite loosening invested
two moves here 95 and back and I
probably that's all okay for white but
couldn't really see him something grades
are so went for that Wow okay that's not
exactly a move I expected I'm very
ambitious can check everything off and
then d 6 is hanging that's really an
issue
okay okay oh I didn't expect that move
actually hmm okay stinking Bishop takes
was this idea a ticket okay maybe I can
maybe I can play the check yet as an
important resource maybe I can play that
Knight takes bishop d4 check yeah it's
probably probably still not good yeah I
have a I have some doubts hear about the
validity of my position it all seems to
just one hang-hang seems to be hanging
by a thread just Knight takes bishop d4
check seems to work at least it doesn't
lose big material and got him to pause
we'll see disconnected
nope i'm also not disconnected so he
said really taken aback by that move
strange yeah it doesn't doesn't show a
disconnect to the ping but this seems a
bit like there's there's some technical
problem white forfeits due to
disconnection yeah what is shame it was
a really interesting position I mean I
can be I probably can be very glad that
it happened because I'm bear in a bad
position man I can just take that I
wasn't sure about that the computer
gives it as good for wide I thought I
can t applicant play here but III is
indeed possible yes yeah this is not
good at all and then then then my
position was really rubbish it looked
like that but I was I was so it wasn't
totally sure ok well the engine wants to
take him interesting and it gives be
takes yeah I was more concerned about
Queen takes but then Queenie five is
given as still quite ok hmm it is
surprising especially the week t6 pawn
looks looks difficult to play gin but
the engine is not giving much oh yeah 95
was a huge what it was a huge loss of
time maybe it wasn't ok here i could
have here can take and play Queen five
that's really possible I was really i
mean the compounds to take with the pawn
but maybe this is just good by the way I
mean what has the idea to just play see
form and in some cases and well just
make this completely stable this
construction and they have a high
time to ever move this night due to
Knight f6 yeah right is just better him
yeah it's a problem of the modern benoni
it's not an opening that tolerates many
second rare red moves and if you don't
know it like I do so that that means
that this wasn't a good idea h5 and I
decided on that relatively quickly yeah
the compounds to do this well I'm not
saying that this is necessarily the best
but it's probably better than then aged
5 I really did not assess that correctly
the night coming to you for was really
very annoying that looks that looks kind
of okay I mean I have those ideas like
night back maybe 90 95 yeah I have
ordered a new mouse but it's not yet not
yet in inaction and that's kind of weird
what it's drawing yeah this is this
looks too much more reliable maybe
trying to activate the bishop and night
that way and I still have the beef I'll
play yeah I was bhatia when the nitre
was showing up there only four it was
really a problem and I could never
really i mean okay at this I haven't
covered e6 first but I can never really
go here right this is I mean trying to
kind of untie this knot I can stick
antique and chat jump here and my or
King position is looking like Swiss
cheese hmm yeah the Benoni took him yeah
lucky with the disconnect them okay well
thanks for watching